about 42,000 Americans are reported to
have recovered from the corona virus
that's according to Johns Hopkins we
wanted to see what it's like for
patients who have gotten better
including the possible effects on their
mental health or dr. Terra Narula spoke
with a doctor who recovered after he
spent days on a ventilator this
uplifting video taken last week at New
York's Staten Island University Hospital
shows veteran physician Michael
sherita's release from his own Hospital
after a more than two-week battle
against the corona virus I was intubated
for three days I remained in the ICU for
probably an additional six days doctor
sharifa had been treating patients only
days before contracting the virus but is
now at home resting feeling fatigued and
on oxygen support did they talk to you
about any possible long-term damage to
any of the other organ systems I was
really grateful because heart disease
runs in my family I have hypertension
I'm saying I hope my arteries are good
because this is really a stress test you
know and I realize that all the organs
are tied in kovat 19 is a virus that
involves the respiratory tract that can
damage the lungs and require mechanical
ventilation but experts believe the
impact of the virus isn't limited to
just the lungs this is a condition that
at a taxi entire body that can attack
the heart and the kidneys in the liver
it can attack the coagulation system the
endocrine system the neurologic system
dr. Harlan krumholz is a professor of
medicine at Yale University so just
because somebody has survived the acute
episode they've been excavated they've
gone home from the ICU doesn't mean that
they're out of the woods cognitively
physically either mental health can be
affected I mean there's all sorts of
things that happen afterwards so we need
to provide support it's not like you hey
you've been through this and you're done
but they need to be understood as
continuing to be vulnerable for some
time so you know we don't want to freak
people out we don't want to scare people
we don't want to contribute to the
greater anxiety but we want people to be
informed that this is a big deal Gail
it's important to remember as we monitor
patients going forward for concerns with
other organ systems
we can't forget about the psychological
system we know that in patients who
survived critical care illnesses or been
in the ICU they are at risk for
development of PTSD or depression so
important for families providers friends
to really be aware of that as well as
the patient's themselves as a doctor
Tara I can't imagine what it's like for
doctors to see one of their own recover
because you all know exactly how hard
that might have been for that particular
person that was great video thank you
dr. Tara Narula